[Musique]
je m'appelle Nassim j'ai 29 ans
vous avez entendu parler de la justice
restaurative
ce que vous proposez à ces gens c'est
l'inverse parce que tout le monde leur a
toujours proposé on ne parle pas à leur
place on ne suggérer rien on écoute on
accueille inconditionnellement
j'aimerais revoir mon frère j'ai pas
envie de le croiser par hasard enfin je
veux le voir pour être sûr de pas le
croiser par hasard j'étais agressé dans
le supermarché dans lequel je
travaillais à 5 ans je suis là pour vous
dire ce qui se passe pour les victimes
quand vous commettez genre de choses
j'ai 25 ans et j'ai braqué une supérette
j'ai passé toute ma vie dans le monde
des stupéfiants ça fait 25 ans que je
fais des allers-retours entre la prison
et l'extérieur je suis plus comme avant
ma vie est plus comme avant
et si je résume avant elle était même
[Musique]
quand vous parlez de peur vous voulez
dire quoi exactement quand vous attaquez
quelqu'un il n'y a pas qu'une victime il
y a d'autres victimes derrière il y a
des familles des couples des enfants
mais des petites claques c'est pour
impressionner mais des claques c'est des
cons en vrai j'ai l'impression j'ai
jamais rien décidé dans ma vie assume
nous sort pas tes excuses débiles tu le
prépares pas en fait moi tu me prépares
moi ça fait des mois que je bosse comme
une chienne que j'ouvre tous les
dossiers
si vous leur laissez un espace pour
réfléchir mais ils vont réfléchir sinon
ils vont dire ce qu'ils ont toujours dit
à tout le monde et ils vont taire ce
qu'ils ont toujours tue je comprends pas
cette violence on est là pour favoriser
leur réparation
j'ai perdu mon frère quand j'ai porté
plainte en fait et ça me fait de la
peine parce que j'adorais mon frère
c'était mon grand frère
[Musique]